the world was left reeling from the
unexpected death of chadwick boseman who
fell victim to colon cancer at the age
of 43.
it was a battle he fought privately
while filming some of his biggest movies
from mcu staples notable biopics to
spike lead joints during his fight
against cancer
after appearing in several other biopics
including 2013's 42
and 2014's get on up where he played
jackie robinson
and james brown respectively bozeman
continued this tradition by
playing pioneering supreme court justice
thurgood marshall in 2017's
marshall directed by reginald hudlund
the film focuses specifically on one of
the earliest and most important cases of
marshall's career
state of connecticut versus joseph spell
i only represent
innocent people people accused because
of their race that's
my mission i never touched that woman
connecticut versus spell concerned a
black man who was falsely accused of
sexually assaulting a wealthy white
woman
after that particular case in which
marshall passionately fought to prove
spell's innocence
he went on to become the first black
justice on the supreme court of the
united states
marshall performed well with critics who
frequently singled out
bozeman's central performance peter
travers of rolling stone said that the
film succeeded based on bozeman's
dramatic lightning
by this point bozeman had already proved
he was king of the biopic
despite his difficult ongoing illness
the first standalone film for the mcu
that featured a black superhero as its
protagonist had a lot to prove
and thanks to bozeman and director ryan
coogler 2018's black panther still
managed to surpass
even the highest of expectations a
critical smash that also crushed the box
office
and even won multiple academy awards
black panther is the first solo film to
star
bozeman's t'challa the young king of
wakanda
who also masquerades as the nation's
premier superhero
imbued by the power of the mythical
black panther and aided by the
incredible technological prowess of
wakanda
which the country keeps secret from the
rest of the world t'challa seems
unstoppable
until his cousin eric killmonger stevens
who feels utterly wronged by wakanda
returns to challenge t'challa for the
throne superhero movies require plenty
of suspension of disbelief
and as a result sometimes they can feel
fake or forced
but black panther succeeds largely
thanks to kugler's careful
loving direction and bozeman's grounding
central performance
most importantly bozeman takes his
legendary superhuman figure
makes him feel like a real person
infusing him with a lightness and
serious intensity
all at the same time
black panther the character appeared in
plenty of mcu properties but black
panther the movie turned out to be one
of the best
and most culturally important
stand-alone outings in the cinematic
universe's history
after the events of black panther
t'challa makes the decision to open up
about wakanda's true power
inviting the world to see their
technological advances
however he doesn't expect that one of
the biggest battles for humanity will be
fought on their
land in 2018's avengers infinity war
the climactic final battle against
thanos takes place in wakanda but the
heroes ultimately lose
leading thanos to snap his fingers and
eradicate half of all living creatures
with the help of his infinity stone
packed gauntlet
as a result t'challa finds himself
randomly chosen as one of the fallen
leaving wakanda bereft thankfully in
2019's end game the remaining heroes
figure out a way to bring back their
fallen friends
and t'challa is among the first to
return to the world of the living
not only does bozeman get an emotional
moment before battle and infinity war as
he leads wakanda into the fray
proving his medal as their king but he
also gets the first entrance back into
the real world
appropriate for his stature as an
audience favorite infinity war and end
game are both
huge ensemble films but thanks to
bozeman t'challa stands out from the
pack
bozeman took a brief breather from the
mcu with 21 bridges in which he plays an
nypd detective alongside stars like
sienna miller
jk simmons and taylor kitsch after two
criminals kill police officers during a
heist
detective andre davis played by bozeman
is tasked with stopping the men as
quickly as possible
to try and prevent them from escaping he
shuts down all 21 bridges connected to
manhattan to trap the duo on the island
hunting them throughout the night are
you going to do this close the island
it's no surprise that leading roles like
21 bridges came along in the wake of
bozeman's work in the mcu
and naturally he was praised for his
central performance with critics calling
him a more than capable leading man who
elevates the story with his cool
charisma
21 bridges may have been a standard cop
drama at face value but
clearly bozeman proved to be just the
right actor to make it into something
special
the story of a group of elderly vietnam
veterans who returned to the empty
battlefield to find treasure
as well as the squad leader they buried
there the five bloods plays with time
especially as it pertains to bozeman's
character stormin norman earl holloway
in fact norman is the lost squad member
the titular five bloods are searching
for
along the way they grapple with their
past present and future as they try to
do right by their fallen comrade
bozeman's role is small yet pivotal into
five bloods and ultimately
nobody could explain why he was chosen
for this vital role better than lee
himself
as lee told writer david sims in the
atlantic ahead of the film's 2020
release
here's the thing for me this character
is heroic
he's a superhero who do we cast we cast
jackie robinson
james brown thurgood marshall and we
cast
t'challa chad is a superhero
that character is christ-like notice the
way the cinematographer newton thomas
siegel shot him
there's light from heaven coming down
from above on him
bozeman may be gone but one of his films
has yet to be released
based on a play by the same name written
by famed black playwright august wilson
who penned classics like fences ma
rainey's black bottom will mark
bozeman's final film role casting him
opposite academy award winner viola
davis
the story of one day in the studio with
famed recording artist ma rainey played
by davis
and her willful trumpeter levy played by
bozeman
ma rainey's black bottom will certainly
make waves when it hits netflix
though the release date has been pushed
back out of respect for bozeman